hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to sort the court now
the last time I played this game was
almost two years ago to the day and
since then it's received one more major
update so I'm gonna play it and in
addition to that you get to play as a
king or queen and I don't think that was
in the game before but now I'm gonna be
a queen I'm beautiful hello my lady I'll
help you rule your kingdom and no I
don't get it
very funny just give people their
answers okay our city is still very
small right now but it certainly has a
potential to grow perhaps one day we
will have a bustling metropolis and
you'll be invited to join the Council of
crowns I don't remember there being a
Council of crowns before for now all you
need to concern yourself with is keeping
the citizens happy and growing our
population
do your best madam I shall I shall
venture to do my best
hello want me to steal from the rich and
give to you not just the rich I'll steal
from whoever basically that's morally
ambiguous
I'm not morally and excuse me I'm trying
to get my foot in a comfortable position
here that's not more I am NOT a morally
ambiguous individual go to hell
taking the high road huh I'll see you
around alright whatever I actually was
trying to move my foot in a comfortable
way everybody just bear with me I don't
know how long the video is gonna be when
I'm done but I'm taking the long road
for this one oh hi it's just staring at
me does it want something yeah it does
it sure does Oh what just happened I
feel lucky oh god it's my lucky day
thank you thank you I goodbye hey I am
the Duke of spook do you want that
spooky nickname of course I do little
Fang you can be the creep queen that
I'll take it alright I'm the creep queen
hi
hello butt demon hey bud care to flip a
coin with me heads I'll give you a bunch
of gold tails I take a bunch of your
people's souls well I mean I feel pretty
lucky so why not oh oh oh oh it's tails
I'll be taking those souls better luck
next time
well that's inconvenient
well at least I have money people are
sad the city is shrinking what the
people are one-off from sadness but
people are at the baseline is a hundred
but it's running wild should we try to
capture it yeah we should
oh whoa this thing is dangerous it just
killed somebody how did that chicken
kill grandma here I was considering
opening up a soup shop yes of course
grandma there's literally no way that I
would not do that for grandma and
somehow grandma brought our whole family
of ten people involved I'll sell my soup
in the town square
thanks grandma my lady I wish to embark
on a treacherous quest you go you go man
do you do you think for the kingdom I
shall return to you lady alright thank
you take care with you whatever I named
small debt do you want anything to know
the truth about everything you're gonna
want to hire me okay I'm gonna go we
investigate something I think smoulder
oh hey how's it going
one of our prisoners escaped may I have
some gold offer a reward for her
recapture yeah okay Oh someone's bound
to find her soon with this sweet reward
I'm kind of running out of gold here
place were a little better off people
are sad does it go up to 200 what about
your baloney what a bunch of malarkey
ook he's got a shiny coin okay always to
instruct a tavern I'm trying to get in
New York accent going on for this guy
hey I wish to construct a tavern but
I'll need some gold from you to make it
happen that's terrible guys the worst
let me try again
start with constructor Tavernier hey I'm
constructing a tavern here I wish
to construct a tavern but I'll need some
gold from you to make it happen I'm
talking considerable not a gold couple
under at least what do you think I only
have 195 but if that's okay I'll do it
well the town's folk will be happy
to have a place to drink all right well
I'm dirt poor so
that's not good the Treasury is empty
m'lady we could raise taxes a bit
further but the people won't like it
much
should we try no it's okay we'll make up
the gold somehow we still need to
resolve the issue of having no money
we'll get to it eventually but not at
the cost of happiness you seems like you
need some gold in exchange for a few
souls maybe how about it no suppose
you'll have to look elsewhere for the
coin then yeah that would just make him
unhappy and that's what I just didn't do
for the tower we need of cash I could
hook you up if you let me eat a few
folks how about it
No thank you Chester I used to find some
other way out of this myth huh yes I
will Chester people are happy the city
is growing well that's good we get some
tax money no Chester stop no no bad
chests bad treasure is empty we could
raise taxes I guess better than letting
them eat people oh we still lose yeah
all right well we got money from taxes
so I guess that's good
hey working conditions are unsafe will
you please spend some gold on improving
our ability to work I am I'm the worst
yeah okay safety is my number-one
concern
thank you the builders appreciate this
Frick I feel awful and the Duke of spook
do you want this book a nickname yeah
sure you can be the crepe queen the bow
is already the creep Queen I'm ready to
make my report seems the merchants guild
is being controlled by alien
conspirators how do I know this
sometimes you just know you know yeah I
know I get you yeah I know you know
you're know er thanks thanks for
noticing my knowing people are sad the
city's shrinking I was just passing
through and thought you might like some
magic I never say no to magic
[Music]
goddammit our city is dying because of
my negligent ability to rule
oh look of coin flipper let's throw this
ah ah alright well you seem
to be a giant piece of hello any
mystery 2-foot I can do some snoopin for
a small fee okay you go you snoop you
snoop it up you get the truth whatever
it may be however it may help me hi oh
god you haven't been talking to Scalia
have you know if you say so
I sure have an alien hey bud careful
alright this time you better you better
get it to me ah there we go
thank you thank you Georgie my people
are pissed off there's a party going on
in the tavern the citizens rejoice
singing and dancing together into the
night I am a bad ruler I'm a bad queen
we lost a quarter of our populate we
lost a third we lost a third of our
population in one day god damn it you
ever seen your treasure chest do a back
flip no I honestly never have where
you're not gonna okay thank you
grandpa hello sweetie can I borrow a
coin for the newspaper of course you
can't grandma
any time Thank You dearie a petition to
bring the circus to town is circulating
could attract tourists are you
interested yeah around the clown's there
we go let's have the circus in without
was nothing but good that was those
nothing but good there was nothing but
Chi yes okay thank you now I've got
money but my people are still gonna
leave me oh whoa
might I juggle your balls yeah okay oh
very good
all right thank you French juggler the
circus is in town bringing joy to all
who visit it also happens to bring a
nice bit of golden cool my people are
still leaving but this next day is gonna
be a new day
there's a bunch of goblins in the lower
corner I'll slay him for a few gold if
you want ok go for it have fun also
enough cramps my lady I have returned
I'm ashamed to inform you that I
returned with nothing shall I show
myself to the dungeons Oh No you're fine
you forgive me Oh kind and gracious Lord
bless you I didn't sneeze but thank you
I'm such a good Queen there's a very
stinky kid running around the streets
should we force her to have a bath
yes hygiene is of the utmost importance
glad you agree she won't be happy though
well sucks to suck you gotta be clean
him might I'd get us a cup of tea for
you milady
ok sure yes nice and hot madam
alright you freakin weirdo why you gotta
be weird like that hello it seems happy
okay good that's good Serkis is still
going and wheeze are happy Oh
wheeze are happy Oh wheezes so a happy
or wheezing the happiest oh look at us
and how happy weaves is grandma I read
quite the troubling tale in the paper
today you think everything will be
alright grandma are you kidding me
everything said to be just fine grandma
you have nothing to worry about I hope
you're right I am right grandma a visit
anytime grandma I've collected some
incomes from the circus would you like
me to tax them yes very well the
proceeds will be added to the Treasury
that's how income works right huh whoa
take the girl I mean the gold take the
gold
don't take my people oh yes I'll
take that good god man jeez good day
madam do you require any haunting
services for a small price I'll scare
some people for you ah no thank you
very well very well I mean I didn't need
it miss your spirit I would like some
money please
sure cuz we're just handing tonight oh
my god thank you for the money good
madam this is good money
why did I give you money who the hell
are you yet who this is a bit of a
kerfuffle we're in a bit of trouble I've
got a business proposition for you in
your tiny little town are you interested
well you're a little insulting you dick
but okay I will bring you details soon
all right you're teasing piece of
garbage
oh hi hey pal you've been a real great
sport so I wanted to give you this
no strings attached really oh thanks
thank you that's so nice the people have
started a petition to ban pineapples in
the city should we do it no I love
pineapples sticking up for pineapples
how admirable up who doesn't love
pineapples
now pineapples on pizza that's a de ba
mination but an escaped prisoner has
been recaptured thanks to the bounty you
offered our citizens can rest no easier
okay I accidentally ate some folks out
front can I pay you back with gold yes
oh thanks for understanding nope nope
nope nope no problem care to gaze into
my magical vampire crystal art if you
whip your dick out again I'm going to be
incredibly pissed but I will look oh
come on our city can't take this you see
death and mr. screw you screw you and
your magic balls my boats too tiny to
catch many fish can I have some gold to
upgrade that stop pay back I swear all
right go for it we've got gold and no
people oh you won't regret this you'll
see thank you nice beard hello sweetie
can I borrow coin of course grandma
always grandma you got a skeleton of
your own you know don't you find it
weird that you can't see it no not that
weird no you don't think anything's
weird do ya
no not not really I mean the dragon that
walked its way in here hey could I
trouble you for a sandwich
surely the cost of one sandwich is
nothing - to a great queen like you oh
my god I'm sorry
I am sorry yeah okay take a sandwich
fantastic hey I'm excited to eat this
it's like some horrible Christopher
Walken hybrid oof we're doing poorly
we're doing poorly oh hi mom says I need
to ask your permission to go on an
adventure so can I please please yes go
for it yeah I'm excited
alright why do you need my permission
citizen say a monkey has been running
around flinging stuff at them should we
put a bounty on it yeah go for that
we'll have that monkey captured in no
time oh hi buddy I'm ba ba bum ba dum
bum Boosh you like my rhythm bra I am a
lady but that's okay I'll overlook it
nice rhythm yeah I'm in the groove
alright okay thank you we've captured
some foes on the battlefield shall we
bring them home and put them to work
well that sounds like slavery so no I
understand however we need to do
something with them till we ransom the
captured foes off for a bit of gold yes
very well better to have golden hostile
captives thank you I think why did you
need to yell at me oh hi big guy home
the blacksmith and I'd like to set up
shop here I can pay my own way I just
need your permission what do you say
okay yeah I'll show you my incredible
skill just you wait thank you thank you
there's a party going on the tavern hell
yeah okay citizens are upset about
whether or not ransoming our prisoners
was the right choice there's been some
unrest about the decision well too
freaking bad what were we gonna do keep
up here there would have been pissed and
killed people whatever
police were growing
madam I heard about the dragon attack
you were made to endure I've come up
with an idea to strike back I can craft
a blade powerful enough to slay the
dragon and Draco those treasures won't
be easy though I need to track down the
finest metals but they're quite costly
might I have a few hundred gold to begin
my search okay go for it
thank you madam I'll keep you posted
about further developments I won't let
you down
I'll strike back at that dragon yet okay
you better cuz we're poor both people
poor happy poor and gold poor I saw a
beautiful silver gauntlet in the
blacksmith today may I have the funds to
purchase it okay yeah sure you're the
knight I guess thank you lady I shall
use it in defense of our proud Kingdom
okay thank you
a caravan of mine wishes to camp in your
city for the next few days might that be
arranged
okay quite agreeable we shall work
together again I hope you still need to
tell me about that the thing oh you all
right buddy all right Gandalf we're
gonna trust you again
I never say no to magic I should have
said no to magic
why isn't there dare for magic god damn
it I'm back I found these shiny yellow
stones pretty cool right yeah pretty
cool so cool well thank you guess that
helps a little bit citizens been trading
within that good people are sad the city
is shrinking I'm sad I've got a business
proposition
yeah I am okay cool is the caravan the
business proposition okay whatever
reporting in I discovered an underground
crime ring in the city's eastern ward
I've already taken steps to break up
their operations can I have a bit of
extra gold to bring in the guards and
make some additional arrests yeah go for
it
it seems like a good use perfect we'll
have those criminals locked up in by
this time another man tomorrow
you okay I never say no to magic I never
say no to magic if you screw me over
again delft there will
be no limit to my rage what kind of bad
luck hi grandma I'm sorry grandma it's
fine everything's gonna be fine grandma
grandma everything is going to be just
fine don't worry don't worry grandma the
guild of pineapple traders offers you a
gift madam will you accept it yes if
please be pint of oh that's good enough
okay
people are sad they're gonna leave great
yeah looks like he wants something
Patty's belly okay yes please thank you
morale boots okay
[Music]
he's so enthralled by you and your abs
that's what I thought oh I'm so into it
yeah you're you are please just go away
oh sure my name is madam a bear a bear a
bear my name is madam agua and I've come
to join your court will you have me yep
how sweet
I'm sure many wonderful adventures await
us I'm sorry who cook he's got a shiny
coin yes he does yes he does not again
Dan Delfy I swear to God I swear I swear
I'm gonna close my eyes I'm gonna look
at yes okay I'm gonna close my eyes I'm
gonna press yes and you are gonna give
me something good hey that was not worth
it two hundred two hundred thousand god
damn you dirtied a14 worse hi you find
me humorous that's that's so fun it's a
good it's a good one cheer me right up
cheer this whole town up we're gonna
grow now Oh God
hey it's slime day got a present for me
yeah okay you're so nice I sure AM slime
man hello
your beautiful plants are interesting
don't you think I would like to open a
garden may I have some workers to help
me yeah my town my tiny town hey I'd
like to build a granary this could help
expand our population but it'll cost a
bit okay you got it
this will help our city grow my lady I
wish to embark on a treacherous quest go
for it for the kingdom I shall return to
you lady alright thank you
oh look the people are happy the extra
food we've been able to store in the
granaries is attracting more settlers
shall we let them in yeah okay very good
we'll have them settle it in once okay
we're climbing back out of the brink we
were at the bottom don't you don't no no
no I can't say no to magic I can't say
no I never say no thank you
dad ow you're really fueling my gambling
addiction and never say no how hundun no
no no go away go go get out of here stop
you just can't seem slightly magical not
sure what it wants though
I never say no to magic so okay I guess
that's good
hello buddy it seems sad oh that's
helpful the people are happy the city's
growing my lady
there's a man in the for yay asking to
join your God he's got an eyepatch looks
little shifty what do you think should
we take a chance on this stranger
listen I've taken chances on wizards
magical chests flying but demons
eyeballs why would I be bothered by a
normal stranger indeed most walls would
help us hello the guards confiscated
some gold that I found no no no no
you're keeping it but I stopped I mean
how'd it go
accidentally stand about not eating
candies can I have some girl to get to
the dark door yes I never thought I
could eat too many sweets Oh aren't you
just delightful hello did you exist
before I don't think I can fix you but
I'll try thanks friend
I am become fixed alright you and become
go to the English teacher because you is
not good at that
I love madam are you looking for
experience bobbles and you're caught
well if you're implying that you're an
experienced barber and you walk in here
looking like you stuck your head in a
blender I'm gonna say yes they're not
shuts on you I'm the best of the best
but cast with not being able to cut my
own hair only the hair of others well at
least we're growing hey we're making
progress we're finally climbing back Oh
God want me to do a drumroll
alright here we go
yes I knew you'd like it
all right thanks buddy ah
why must you darken my doorway wizard
I've been playing for maybe twenty days
you've been here for six of them yes
Oh My Luck has turned around my gambling
addiction is being fueled probably not a
good thing but Hugh yeah there's been a
brawl at the tavern should we arrest
those responsible for starting it people
fight it's fine just nice it's all good
it's fine
no but they're sure to cause more
trouble if Oh wait no wait wait no wait
come back
arrest them I change my mind it is nice
to see you madam do you like my new
haircut
ah instead of a blender you decided to
stick to frisky beavers in your hair and
let them go to town inside of you ah
okay my lady I have returned I'm ashamed
again it's fine but why do you keep
going on these quests if you're not
getting anything
no you forgive me yes I forgive you why
I didn't even throw people that fought
in the tavern into the dungeons why
would I throw you we're almost at where
we started yeah you feeling spooky today
yes I am heck oh wait no wait no wait no
that's no no man you hide earlier I was
gone missing shall we send a search
party yes uh-huh
let's find him at all costs okay
yes I'm making the wrong choices yeah
hello sweetie yes grandma yes you can
your visits always brightened on my day
thank you grandma you're so sweet
I love you would you like to purchase
any sports for your cards
oh well protect the city as a happy City
yep sure would thank you great of a
shipment a sword sent to your barracks
that was actually pretty cheap a penis
there so I'm down for that for some
reason when I look at that camel
it looks like it's balls arresting in
the middle of its chest I don't know why
yeah we're growing 120 hey we're finally
making progress okay I'm not gonna make
the same mistake twice you arrest those
bastards you string them up you send
them to the dungeon you stick him in the
iron maiden you tickle their Tootsie's
yes okay
I was forgiving before but not now mom
made us steal from that no did no no no
no yes no yes listen no yes no no no no
citizens from far and wide come to visit
my barbershop would you like a fresh new
cut madam free of charge
okay sure of course you do you look
dashing I don't look any different
I'm literally no different there's
nothing that's hello squee there's a
mouth should we chase it away Petit's
well no it's just reading what's wrong
with that
it seems happy okay thank you madam
about the dragonblade yeah it's what I'm
calling the sword now I've purchased
some top-quality metals but I'll need
workers to help me and do the crafting
can you spare a few yes this will speed
things up I shall return to you with a
magnificent blade madam thank you
blacksmith
all right we are growing fast now huh ma
come on feeling spooky today no opposite
of spooky not even a tiny spook a little
baby bad no no blood is gonna flow today
god damn you you the handsome bastard
give it to me oh that's been pretty good
luck so far I never say no to magic baby
all right look hey buddy maybe it's time
to hang up the sword you obviously can't
do all right go for it all right
goodbye I'm a little Timmy nice to meet
you
you like ice queen yeah I do uh-huh
me too okay then you little Timmy you're
adorable but also creepy I was to put on
a show may I have the funds to do so
okay oh very good why there's so many
French people in my city people are
happy the city is growing yes finally
good God Oh get your butt back alone in
there Oh thinking you may be interested
in something a little bigger hey what
kind of something are you talking about
and how much bigger are you suggesting
maybe some kind of devilish ritual
something along those lines a lot of
souls would get you so let's I guarantee
you can afford it though not gonna wipe
out your whole city here just lots of
folks but on the other hand you'll get
crazy amount of money like I'm talking
serious gold beeps here I gotta do it
tonight
moon special right now one chance only
what do you say um well gold how much is
a heap uh yeah no that's a tempting um
probably a bad idea but I mean
everyone's probably screaming at me to
go no but just I'm I'm kind of tempted
by the heaps
oh my god it's piled up to my ears and
beyond
[Music]
[Laughter]
enjoy your riches Bob maybe I'll see you
around again sometime who knows Wow
thank you care to gaze into my magical
vampire crystal all right that didn't
work before but you said magical and I
literally cannot say no to magic Oh pile
a little more trickle it up on top there
can I have a coin a gold coin alright
listen kid I can't spare a single dime
listen I have got to budget myself hey
go for it kid buy you some ice cream
alright cool I think my my spina bifida
is gonna get worse from hunching over
from this gold some of the villagers
mentioned they saw an alien walking
around you know anything about this I do
yes I do I knew it I need to go find
molder okay fine builders wish to
construct more houses they request gold
which would be modified okay go for it
mmm I've got plenty of gold our city
grows it grows richer good great we got
32 people today it's a hundred
I think I'm a good queen you call this a
cat yeah I eat a dick if you can you
ghost
indeed it is for question oh okay what
oh okay there it is
demand for mice ever ceases throw the
roof now have your permission to raise
my prices
I mean supply and demand go for it I
guess oh people are happier the Baba's
Association thanks yeah okay it's been a
brawl at the Travers I throw them in
jail arrest them at once oh oh names
Mulder wait I already hired I know you I
I'm aware of you Mulder go to gaze into
my magical yeah I die you sack of
oh you little piece of garbage you piece
poor Barry my show seems to have gone
over well I wish to expand my production
funds I shall need fell hundred gold oh
well I don't know if I have the goal
despair but go for it
oh this sure will delight and astound ah
my cold it's only up to my ears now any
mysteries afoot okay well you said you
were gonna go talk to Mulder so you
didn't did you bunch of goblins go for
it slay those goblins I'll show those
creeps man your hips are just
unbelievable
villagers are complaining about garbage
in the streets shall we hire workers to
clean it up yes
villagers noses will thank you Shirley
Shirley don't call me Shirley
grandma the soup shops been doing well I
came to offer you some of our earnings
grandma grandma no keep that for your
scram I no need no grandma no
you are so humble I'm so come on crying
so sweet
grandma goddamnit grandma demand for my
services alright fine go for it I guess
that's a messy how hire your service is
then oh hi buddy my boat's all fixed up
thanks to you something's up and you're
back for your loan
thank you a nearby town is asked as to
form an alliance with them should we use
them to beef up our ranks okay sure
whoa easy-peasy just more people all
right I found a way to summon people
from another dimension oh okay
Oh magic of questionable origins well I
never say no to magic so there's that
thank you
the extra food more setlist what is this
just people our Wow okay we're up to 200
goblins go for it go for him this is
going great now we're on a roll there's
no way that we could lose okay hello you
ready for the truth aliens have landed
in there in our city you think we're
safe no no no we're not worrying won't
change anything they're already here
among us oh well they're adding to the
population so I guess that's good my
sales have brought in record profits and
I'd like to give you something will you
accept my gift oh sure
very good very good thank you I do
believe I have perfected my shawl gold
it does require but happiness it shall
bring oh 700 gold my lord
I can put my show 1 small your show
hasn't done garbage why why am I giving
Gold why why am i I've given you like
1500 gold why I mean am I still giving
you gold no no no no my gold Oh the
gesture continues to amaze the core with
a combination of a skill and his ever
increasing special effects budget well I
guess that's good
happiness is the root of all and happy I
don't know we're growing fast and I
guess that really was what matters madam
the city's population is growing
steadily in our records of citizenship
indicate that 250 people now call the
city home but the bigger city will need
to maintain even higher happiness in
order to keep people satisfied make sure
you pay attention to the citizens and
their issues to raise our happiness
remember earlier when I mentioned the
Council of crowns yeah I heard a rumor
that one of their members had started
searching the land for a new ruler to
join them perhaps they are aware of our
progress okay I'll join I'll do that
hey uh somebody came by and cleaned my
home you're gonna pay me back for them
yeah yeah I guess I guess this soon dude
I mean I can't really make slime for you
so no we'd like to purchase any swords
from my guards
well protective have a sitter yep we are
happy as a clam grab ah oh grandma no
you keep them grandma you keep it
grandma
you keep it I really want them how are
you it seems your court is without a
much cake I can provide cake I'm a Kate
chef may I join you
yeah okay Louis you're you're more than
welcome here thank you
bye Kate will make you cakes
can be sure of that all right Thank You
Louis scary scary Louis okay all right
Louis Louis everybody hey we're growing
faster that's what matters the town we
made an alliance with it's in trouble
should we send soldiers to a system yes
of course that's what alliances are
force we promised we would protect them
I have returned from Mike Wow Thank You
night you're in for a reward later hello
want some of the patties belly okay I
mean this is going great I don't know
what the Council of crowns is all about
but I'm gonna find out you think you owe
me slimeball it's hurting my feelings
yeah of course thanks boss no one ever
calls me boss thanks Winston um again I
don't know what scaring people would do
but okay I guess ah why do you want me
to school god damn it you and your trick
questions I just wanted to know what it
was like all right we're growing that's
all that matters
hey we're big can I have some food yeah
of course boots yeah it's the same mouse
from before is he offering me something
yeah oh you found a coin oh what a cutie
care to gaze into my magical vampire
curse oh my god if you take away my
people I'm not gonna kill you okay I'm
not gonna kill you I'm not gonna kill
you here find your oh god no no
just go okay I got it as orgasmic is
that sounded my god I got a friend from
witch school looking to move to town
yeah go for it
more witches the better I think people
are happy we're grown big we're going oh
look at us look at us look at us look at
us look at us look at us look at us hen
might I get a cup of tea for you milady
yes yes nice in the Hawks indeedy-do
nice and hot indeed that mischievous
monkey has been capped
I shall send them to you for your
judgement oh hi
he's defending his cakes should we
punish him for flinging stuff
listen monkey I don't make the rules
okay yes I make the rules but I am a
slave to the rules just the same as you
and in my city we don't fling poopie if
there was what you were flinging a
monkey is as a monkey is you can't
expect a monkey not to throw poop around
[Music]
this monkey from certain doom you are
free monkey you better not do it again
though not do it again I'm a hero
goddamn hero some very strange creatures
wish to move in the houses we build
should we allow it well I don't want to
discriminate
of course all are welcome in our town
hey ho what is this strange place I
found myself in outlet do you know where
we are
my oh my hello you queenly person there
I do believe I'm a bit lost might I stay
in this town for a while yeah yeah okay
how nice Albert and I shall find an
interstate I'm sure I'll see you again
habit seems to like you okay Thank You
Albert there's a lot of this stuff in
this edition names Mulder I know Mulder
I know yes go investigate the aliens
invading our town oh I am sorry about
earlier my circuits were quite fried I
offer my thanks for your help thank you
quite logical all right our soldiers are
coming home and our assistance in
defending our allies has not gone
unnoticed we've been offered a bounty of
gold by the captain of their military a
good fellow okay thank you eyepatch I'm
back I discovered an inferior to cover
up large amounts of gold
do you believe in aliens I do now good
to know there are other believers out
there okay citizens from far and wide
would you like a fresh cut yes of course
you do you look dashing let's say I look
beautiful but whatever Hey we've reached
500 oh do I get it a reward do I get a
reward Woods back up over my head again
town people are celebrating there's a
huge festival in the square but a
growing population will demand even more
happiness be sure to keep our approval
hi and why just want to give my
congratulations let's keep working hard
okay nah that wasn't meant as a question
I hope you're joking madam I'm never
joking hey why'd you have to go and rat
on me not pass good mold or won't leave
me alone now trying to lead a long life
here I don't need all this commotion
listen you tried to rat out the skeleton
some refugees have arrived in town
should we welcome them yes more people
yeah you again I thought I thought I I
thought you were gone no no no got out
of here you stupid chest any mysteries
afoot yeah go for it
oh the festival in Town Square still
going strong bringing happiness to all
those who attend it's fine whoa oh okay
it's finally done I'll finish crafting
the dragonblade all we need now somebody
to wield it hard leaving here with you
and spread the word our heroes if their
wish to take up the blade I'll send them
here do you cool I've got my night I
guess our granaries stock has been
infected it'll cost us or replace it but
if we don't people could get sick what
should we do save our money that's what
we should do now we'll replace it our
peoples health is worth the cost I agree
but I feel like people should have been
happier about that one my friend from
witch school wanted to thank you for
your help so we made you some magical
cookies all right magical cookies you
say
there's a party I'd like to go to this
evening milady
might I have the rest of the day off yes
go for it have fun thank you we will
toast to your honor
Oh God you this is here to pay it a
visit should we leave it be now get out
of here you stupid bird well this thing
is dangerous every time we kiss a
chicken
well the secret dangerous people are
happy the city is growing
oh I'm Jarno of the comfy Kingdom you
may not believe this but I'm the Royal
assistant of kingpin himself indeed the
very same I've been noodling around this
kingdom of yours and I oh wait what's
that over there uh wha good day madam
did you happen to see a blue fellow come
through here just now strains noodly
limbs made of yarn yes I knew he was
around here somewhere I'm gonna find
that darn yarn oh he's been running
around claiming to be the kingpins royal
assistant which of course he is not in
fact it is I button boy who represents
the competing dominio steam Council of
crowns have you heard of the Council of
crowns good madam oh no really
Council of crowns this group where the
world's top kings and queens gather they
discuss matters of diplomacy trade
warfare and all manner of important
subjects surely as Queen yourself you'd
be interested in joining this council I
have an idea perhaps you'd be interested
in this
that Janos been giving me nothing but
trouble if you could somehow put a stop
to his shenanigans I might be able to
get a meeting with the PR the advisory
of the celestial kingdom if anybody
would be able induct your kingdom into
the house who live would be her what do
you say we help you catch that darn yarn
okay very good
I'll leave the details up to your
discretion once Yano is out of the way
I'll set up a meeting with Pia thank you
for your assistance in this matter of a
good madam I'm sure we will meet again
soon now okay
Oh God you again okay just get it over
and O God thank you they're not to be
able to get all the way okay all right
okay that was pretty good okay my part
nice Kelly told me you have information
about an alien life-form
this true it could change everything I'd
be launching my own independent
investigation I just wanted to come here
and say thank you thank you you get
those dirty rotten alien out of here
well prophets been made in the harbor
and by to share some with you thank you
we've completed our work on the gardener
you please I can't tell but you know I'm
pleased for other reasons so I'm gonna
go ahead and say yeah
I'm so glad I heard you need a champion
to wield that dragon blade
pretty good with swords can take a
finger show our friend the dragon a
thing or two No Oh what is it you don't
trust me absolutely not I absolutely
don't trust you
reporting in I solved the mystery about
who stole mr. mrs. bumpkins baking pan
want me to turn him in yeah sure
crime worth and death it's off to the
dungeon for him bad crime don't do that
uh-oh have you seen my magical cat
pancake
yes actually I have yeah I have actually
very good I knew he was around here
somewhere okay I thought you were here
to darken my doorway but okay cat trying
to tell me something it seems like he
wants help yarn Oh is he talking about
your know maybe this cat could help find
yarn Oh need plenty of tuna of course
but surely it could be worth the cost
well should I hire this cat to find er
no I mean if if any animal could I guess
it's a cat hope he understands what I
want oh well nothing to do but wait okay
the owners of the tavern are making
piles of gold wish to share some with
you that's not usually a thing but okay
I'll take it the spirits are pleased
right now but perhaps you should grant
them an offering of gold I know the
spirit world always appreciates gold and
it might prevent them from haunting us
in the future
200 gold oh sure I guess whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa one of your fishermen has been
bothering me I demand a villager as a
sacrifice
oh no no big no you've angered me now
madam watch your back
okay do you like making new friends I
sure do but and if you consider the one
I just met don't like making new friends
yeah it looks like you want somebody to
Pat his belly okay
all right boots what about yard what
about yarn Oh where's your no okay
goodbye some villagers are threatening
to leave should we pay them a sum of
gold should we listen no screw up get
him out of there no we're not gonna
listen to their demands let's do all of
them go then
it's a dangerous precedent to set we're
not gonna do that
good to go let me stare okay good good
good good
let me steal from the rich and give to
No go away where's my knight where's my
knight oh hello hello I am well I am a
scientist I do science for you Queen you
see the city has grown and we have grown
to the science community that is we now
have our very own council science of
which I am the leader today I simply
wish to introduce myself and now I have
I have I will visit you again in the
future regarding our projects science
projects I think that's two children
stacked on top of each other in trench
coat
hello get in queenly person oh how they
asked me to come here and tell your
story with you a yellow bird meets a
green bird in the garden to see yellow
bird soar higher than the green yes the
yellow bird wheels through the sky she
shimmers in sunlight oh how lovely
oh I would rather have the green if the
green was happiness high up in the sky
the yellow bird meets a blue bird does
heal a bird stop to sing with it yes
oh ho ho the sweet musical notes of the
two new friends filled the air the
singing attracts a flock of nearby birds
of all shapes and colors the skies
filled with song oh what a lovely ending
this story don't you think I would liked
it I would love to come visit you again
sometime queen bee person it's fun to
tell stories with you yeah it's fun now
your stories have kind of magically
affect everything in the real world
around us hey fishermen more broth has
been made in the harbor I came by to
share some with you thank you
oh you again God oh I don't need
happiness that badly the prison is in
need of repairs a few hundred gold yeah
okay oh my money oh oh it's down below
my knees feeling spooky today now Oh
some plant people have sprouted in the
garden are we allowed to make them
official citizens oh okay that's normal
that's that's a little bizarre but okay
some families have moved into the new
houses we built should we send them a
welcome basket yeah that seems nice
you're so sweet and thoughtful God
you're thoughtful okay yeah okay there's
20 happiness that's good that's a lot of
a penis that's good we reached a
thousand that's money that's good the
citizens expect the best from us well
I've got the best to give my Bryn's all
worn out is my birthday I don't feel so
good and no one give me a card all right
fine I have a new room where's the broom
cost $50 what is wrong with you you
swindler I bet it's not even your
birthday hello hello science of council
has devised a blueprint for a gold
generating machine take some time to
construct this and many resources but if
my calculations are correct at least it
will produce gold steadily for the rest
of eternity perhaps you might initiate
this project with 500 gold um yeah okay
good good yes we'll begin construction
right away fires have been breaking out
frequently on cabbage Street shall we
install well to make water more
accessible there yeah
yep they love gold already and of gold
I'm below a thousand gold for the first
time in a long time
they said Oh God why do you all want so
much gold you didn't give me any
happiness in return oh because gold
Jimmy you guys owe me a little yes
let me look okay that's a little gold
that's nice my lady a man wishes to
settle a dispute he says he is way cool
but his friend says is not do you think
he's cool anybody that says they're cool
isn't cool very well I shall inform the
friend of her correctness anyone who
goes like I'm cool like me I say I'm
cool all the time I'm not cool the plant
people citizens have taken root and
grown into a lovely field of flowers can
you hear them rejoicing aha
they are so happy to see the beautiful
plants okay yep bring it on oh hey again
we're gonna on a video game it's a new
thing I came up with think it'll catch
on probably not me too I'm excited about
the possibilities where are your eyes
it's a game you play with others and go
around killing monsters you get a sword
I like the sound of that sounds pretty
cool
yes swords are great right so when you
slay a monster you get experience points
and are you still listening yeah sure
I'm good
well thanks for listening to my idea
thanks for the gold for May letting me
listen to your idea hi grandma isn't it
a lovely day yes it is grandma now that
you're here
very good Deary my lady
might I be the one to take up the
dragonblade and slay the dragon
yeah go for have fun for the kingdom
that dragon will surrender all of its
treasures when I am through yeah okay
fine have fun I guess the people are
demanding that a notorious criminal be
exiled from the city his crimes include
theft arson and forgery what do you say
shall we exile him it sounds pretty bad
yeah I'll do it I'll have the guards do
so why did that cost me money why that
why that cost me money but why that
cause a tiny little town it's big now
we've got like towers and such oh not
you
thank you Oh granary okay replace it Oh
tales of the brave knight of the dragon
blade have spread throughout the city he
gives people hope that's nice that's
nice Oh Road network needs it's us it's
just money money money everything is
money money money
you've been drinking quite a little bit
of tea madam might I upgrade you to the
good stuff yeah yeah first cup is on me
though I'm sure it won't be your last
why me no okay
scientists have constructed a large
factory to further their work on gold
generating machine pollution becomes a
problem for nearby homes those
scientists huh
bunch of douches it's my bounty on her I
had almost given up on him did you get
him did you find euro
you got me that cow just wouldn't leave
me alone until I came back here was the
button boy who sent the cat he's been
trying to steal my position as advisor
for years he claims to be the true
adviser but it's all just a lie he's
only a button after all hi yarn or the
blue and the true advisor of the comfy
Kingdom accept no substitute
oops gotta run huh oh hi Garth seize
that yarn well done madam I'm not sure
how much a part of you actually played
in this but yarn has been found I'm in a
generous mood so I'll set up a meeting
with adviser Pierre of the celestial
kingdom
she's quite busy but you should expect
her to come by sometime soon make sure
this castle is nicely cleaned you'll
want to impress her
since to me all right okay Oh Golda fine
yes take gold can I sacrifice like a
hundred people to get two thousand gold
again I'd really like that that'd be
nice
I hope she didn't hear me say that Oh as
the city grows weak require more gold to
continue expanding our infrastructure an
increase of our construction budget by
say 500 will allow us to build a greater
number of recreational facilities right
thank you
on gold ours will be a city rivaled by
none at this rate Thank You Man thank
you oh off off no oh I don't
have the gold man it's getting tougher
cuz I just don't have a good way I still
see the other town would you like to
purchase swords yeah I'd like to
purchase swords
oh dear those youngsters at the council
of science and making quite a ruckus
with their work could you tell them to
keep it down I would certainly
appreciate a grandma of course yes
are anything for you here's hoping those
whipper snappers will listen I will talk
to them well I told you I don't have
your back your people will do my snacks
II know you dare defy me I'll eat you
all oh can we get someone to deal with
that guy that'd be I need the gold so
I'm gonna say yes but it's not cuz I'm
compromising my morals I just need the
gold they won't even know what hit him
thank you I heard we're expecting an
esteemed visitor from celestial kingdom
shall I go about summoning the servants
to prepare the castle for our great
guests
yes you may of course of course it is
imperative that she be impressed there's
a petition going around open our borders
to the neighboring town what do you say
yep via purse peppers together our towns
grow stronger yes they do yes
they do oh god damn it yeah I just give
me the goal thank you go away please hey
could I trouble you for a sandwich yeah
okay hey how's it going you and me we
will get along though we want to tell
you a secret actually humans because of
curse which put on me I'd stop it if I
could but you know curses you think you
could help me break the curse I don't
want to keep eating people forever I was
going to burn you and frankly for all
the people that you've eaten you
probably should be put to death but
whatever I'll help you I guess thanks
buddy I knew you'd help me keep an eye
out for any magical folks who might be
able to break the curse
okay a whole good day Queen Lee person
friend of mine
Albert wishes me to stop I'd say alone
so hello thank you for letting us stay
in your wonderful city well thank you
goodbye I guess there's some food we've
been able to store on the grand reasons
attract more settlers of course well
people oh yes
I usually looking for someone magical to
help the situation regarding a treasure
chest I give you whatever mystic
assistance you need for a small price of
course thank you miss hips fantastic a
curse is it I'm no stranger to those
I'll have your friends sorted out in no
time okay thank you my god your hips are
incredible
oh we're growing again I didn't know
there'd be a third fit hello greetings I
am Pia advisor the king under Ahmadis of
the celestial kingdom
what a beautiful castle you have here
everything is spotless I was just
wandering through your city and was
quite impressed with your citizens
you know the Council of crowns is
searching for a fifth member is there
something you might be interested in
yeah oh yeah oh yeah I thought as much
I'll inform king under amitis I'm sure
he would be happy to meet you and
discuss the details there thank you
oh my was that the woman from the
celestial kingdom this is so exciting
the celestial King sits at the head of
the Council of crowns any connection
with them will surely do us well in the
future oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy I
mean I've already got a crown so
technically okay this better not be crap
it's crap
you're crap you suck go to hell
the gold generating machine project
continues though we are running low on
supplies more funding modest hundred
gold yeah okay you bunch of swindlers
you bunch of polluting noise-making
swindlers nope hi hello Queen I am a
tree of the Western forests as you can
see however I have been shall we say
shortened this is due largely in fact of
the actions of your team of wood cutters
my home has been chopped clean through
in your reckless pursuit of expansion
you have now disrupted the lives of
myself am i good tree folk brothers and
sisters I demand compensation by the way
of golden coin so that we might repair
this how shall I put it
diplomatic rift between us a policy sum
of 1000
oh yeah yeah yeah I remember last time I
didn't do this and I think it cost me a
lot of problemo so I'm gonna say yes by
Akamai here we go oh the first step on
the path to recovery has been taken well
this does not go unnoticed be sure that
I am not finished i oh yeah yeah I will
be speaking with your Basin immediately
regarding the matter of a sustainable
wood land harvesting you've done the
right thing here today Michel tree folk
will respect that despite your
woodcutters aggression with this epital
good day may you roots go deep and
strong I am poor I am very poor milady I
come across the chest of gold in my
advances will you please accept this
gift yeah thank you thank you night
thank you please night more hi hey buddy
hey I didn't think I'd see you again
yeah I think those yeah thank you thank
you
I'll take good exchange good exchange
could trade good trade good trade good
trade everybody could trade good trade
good trade good trade a search party has
turned up the missing man madam the nine
of his new friends okay can my friends
come over the play okay yeah thank ya
see you Timmy Oh
oh yeah queen lady madam I've done it I
flamed the dragon his hordes are ours
now Wow
I thank you for the opportunity to
service my kingdom it's been an honor
accidently say the romanian candy I hate
you I hate you loud noises are heard
throughout the night from coming from
the Council of Science chambers the
children have a hard time sleeping Oh
God not the children who cares I'm gonna
leave my kingdom now to pursue my dream
of becoming gamedev goodbye okay goodbye
I guess what the hell is that all about
what did you just give me maybe our
paths will cross again one day probably
not though take this card to remember me
by I've got plenty so you can have this
one
okay I can hardly believe it Queen but
we finally done it
construction of the gold general machine
has been completed all that remains is
to turn it on we'll take a couple of
days before it becomes operational but
we'll begin the process tonight won't be
long now no no okay whatever you say if
this consumes all my people Oh God
Oh make way make way for King under
ominous Lord of the celestial kingdom hi
hey how's it going hey hey you don't
always need to make such a fuss about my
entrances Peter anyway yes hello good
Queen I've heard much about you and your
people we and the council are quite
impressed with you and would love to
induct you there's this one small issue
all for the existing council members
must be presently to adduct a new member
but I'm afraid Queen chanterelle and
Queen sareth are having a bit of a fight
at the moment we'll need to calm them
down and settle their dispute before you
can join the council you should be
hearing from their advisers shortly I'm
entrusting you with the task of
reconciling these two Queens best of
luck to you
you'll date it and afterwards that seat
on the council shall be yours
thank you I'll keep an eye out for the
advisors from the Ocean Kingdom and
planned Kingdom madam I'm sure we can
settle whatever it is troubling their
Queens what does that make me the earth
Kingdom tiny little town dude look at
the freaking window yes please thank you
okay good
our work is finally complete the gold
general machine has been activated all
we need now to do is to sit back enjoy
the fruits of our labor many thanks to
you Queen for supporting us in this
project that better be a lot of gold it
better not be one a day since we've
opened our borders travelers from all
over are joining the city doesn't it
just warm your heart they sure do it
sure do it sure do it's a lovely task so
many new friends that's what everyone
considers all the members of their City
friends the council science has said the
most wonderful idea yes yes
okay we've devised an idea to broadcast
music across the entire city using a
network of sonic hardware I'm not sure
if this would be useful but wouldn't it
be fun to try in the name of science I'm
certain we could do it on a budget as
well a mere 100 gold sheets of ice that
sounds terrible that sounds like the
worst idea even if you're gonna just
start blasting music everywhere in our
kingdom the streets will be filled with
song I think that's a bad idea I think
that's a bad idea but I did it anyway I
don't know why wait what the frick bones
you I've just finished moving
in you've been here for two months what
were you doing take one person what the
hell what's wrong with you the gold
generating machine spits out a small
pouch of coins in the night 20-20-20
spit out twenty I figured out a
mysterious new way to make gold wanna
know how okay not telling you okay oh
boy since we opened our borders trade
from caravans is increased dramatically
be wish to tax the merchants yeah that
seems fair it's fair it's fair it's fair
it's fair my friend the curse has been
lifted
I'm not hungry for humans anymore this
is great I feel so free maybe I can find
something better to do with all my money
now a charity work or something it's a
whole new Chester from now on buddy
thank you so much well thank you but
also I liked it money those new speakers
the builders put in a too loud I can't
hear myself think when the music plays
I'm going to be circling a petition to
have them removed though scientists have
gone too far I knew it was bad
[Music]
what's this I hear about a position to
remove the speakers I say I save quite
upsetting you heard about this I had no
idea people were so upset what do you
think do you support the position
yeah remove them get it out err I
suppose is just another failed
experiment for the records you stupid
idiot and me stupid idiot for trusting
you another chapter in the rebuilding of
our people's bond has been penned this
day I've spoken with your Mason on the
topic of sustainable construction
techniques though he was not at first
wholly receptive to my ideologies in due
time I did convince him to see things my
way thank you for cooperation such as it
has been in this matter I didn't do
nothing Hey Oh a very talkative tree
stump just came by to give me an earful
it was saying something about not
cutting down so many trees I think
what's the deal do I have to listen that
thing yes really we're taking orders
from trees now well you're the boss this
will slow down our construction some but
I can't just say no to you madam that
accents gotten worse you think of what
the hell sir Tortuga
um greetings hello I am sir Toto gov the
shell Knights we fight for all that is
good and righteous is there anything on
you might need assistance with you madam
sure oh very good we'll set about it at
once we are very helpful Bunch you'll
see
thank you sir Tortuga I've been asked by
a warrior tribe to the south to supply a
great number of weapons I have your
permission to supply them I'll need some
extra gold to help fill the order okay
that seems dangerous seems like they
might attack us with that whoa whoa whoa
gold gold alright
gonna lag old good day I am adviser
pontus of the ocean Kingdom recently a
dispute has been raised between a queen
the plant kingdom a plot of marshland
has been discovered then must be legally
marked as one kingdom's property since
the NARS contains water clearly it must
belong to the ocean green the plant
clean refuses to listen however and in
CC should be hers we support our claim
to the marsh land will you help the
ocean Kingdom marshland doesn't seem
like it belongs to the ocean Kingdom I
mean if you said that you were the lake
Kingdom I could understand now I want to
Lord you Elizabeth
Charlie you will not believe the March
should go the plant kingdom instead huh
well we shall see about this I will be
going now
Thank You adviser it's a slightly
magical cat from before does it mean
we're friends now of course of course it
does I guess we are we are I knew it the
warrior tribe to the south we provided
weapons for us taking up arms again I
knew it was gonna happen might I request
additional funds so we were able to
adequately yep I knew it was gonna
happen I'm sorry it's come to this but
now we must defend ourselves I knew it
was gonna come to this
I knew ah it's you again huh you those
fishermen and added again giving me a
sacrifice or I swear I'll do something
bad no what do I you've angered me well
I mean you suck you just plain old suck
oh hi um hello my name is advisor agaric
I represent the plant Queen chanterelle
we had the announcement of the ocean
Kingdom is this matter of the marshland
as a land filled with grasses in plant
life that Marsh rightfully belongs to
the plant Queen very far we are of
course spoiled
twelve years of hard I have our thanks
on behalf of the plant kingdom
good day to you this makes sense it
makes sense
oh I think there's something going on in
the sewers on hearing some weird sounds
like you investigate if you want okay
Winston's on ok
Thank You Winston ghostly figures are
seen drifting around the graveyard the
spirits appear to have become angry
that's not good
Oh madam the shell Knights have finished
polishing every statue in the castle to
the maximum level of glorious shine are
are you pleased we can continue to clean
and maybe make some snacks if you wish
yeah that sounds great yeah do that we
will not let you down this castle will
be well looked after I swear it thank
you that's so nice didn't even ask for
money I wish to strengthen the bond
between our cities shall we engage in a
trade mission okay why not quite
agreeable we shall work together again I
hope spirits are haunting the citizens
spread bad luck to the citizens that's
not good oh hello good Queen it seems
the trouble regarding that Marceline has
been all cleared up
once Queen chanterelle realized she won
she was willing to split the marsh with
the ocean Kingdom sometimes a leader
just needs a bit of respect you know
well either way your input helped break
the stalemate for that I am thankful now
as promised your seat on the council
I'll have Peeta make the final
arrangements inform you when we're ready
to induct you thank you again for your
assistance on this matter I've got a
bread roll oh grandma it's okay no it's
okay grandma it's okay oh hello I am
from the neighboring ocean Kingdom what
a lovely castle you have although it is
quite dry have you ever been to yelstin
Kingdom no I see not too much of a
swimmer are you I can't fall here for
wrath I suppose okay goodbye our city
has grown so much that visitors are
becoming quite lost
should we devote more gold the hiring
tour guides I guess yeah okay
the tourists will thank you oh you said
our citizens were getting lost so the I
as our city continues to expand
I'd like to embark on a project that's a
bit more ambitious for a daily allowance
of a hundred gold my workers can begin
the grueling task of remodeling our town
central plaza this will surely elevate
our city to new heights though it may
take
several days to complete what do you
think okay good good
I'll have the logistics of the project
finalized at once and we'll begin work
soon why do you talk so funny 420blaze
oh hi j69 complete hell yeah was we had
42 or 420 on 69 might I have some gold
to make an offering at the ocean shrine
okay thank you the ocean spirits will
surely be pleased okay you're weird
ocean religion madam the shell Knights
have finished a batch of our famous
cookies please partake my Knights will
distribute the rest of your courtiers
the city is looking good the city is
looking good there's got to be like the
final level you uh oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's good stuff the city is
looking good and I bet it's the final
one the shell Knights have completed
their patrol around the castle gardens
picking up litter I'm pleased to say the
gardens are looking spotless thank you
you're so goddamn nice oh there one more
day the new high-class housing district
looks interesting but there's lots of
cool stuff to find there I think I can
borrow the key to the upper district
gate I want to say no but something is
making me say yes
yeah sure no for Alvin
have at it legs altering this I did a
good thing I did a good thing I did a
good thing probably probably where's my
gold making machine
good day madam we're officially ready to
induct you into the Council of crowns
there are a few formalities to observe
can I skip over those and give you the
short version
oh god please do oh thanks it really
doesn't matter in this way
I won't end up losing my voice all right
gather round everybody I'm advice to
Celeste Queens Queens blah blah blah
you're a queen - you're a good queen
we're inviting you you're accepting it's
all very well and good behalf of the
castle crowds I now pronounce you a
crown queen all right we're done you're
in now that you're part of the castle
represented from other kingdoms may come
to help you make sure you do your best
to assist them and sincerely
congratulations Council is the highest
rank to which Queen can rise god damn
central process is complete thanks for
the patience does never look so
beautiful I must say all right I think
I'm gonna end this here I've been
playing it for almost two hours now but
goddess I think about this games it's
just so addicting you just can't stop
pressing forward every single time and I
have no idea why I never say no to magic
and that's a good one to end on that's
pretty good by joining the Council of
crowns you've completed the game you can
continue playing yeah that's so fun
there's something so fun about it like
this count this concept it's not a very
like in-depth concept but I just love it
there's something very addicting about
it you you always want to see how it's
gonna turn out and for those a full game
made it is I mean this is practically a
full game but a bigger expanded game
with more options more more randomness I
think it'd be super fun so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the other parts of this game that I did
in the description below or in the
suggested videos over there and let me
know what you think of it and let me
know if you played it for yourself and
let me know if there's
cool games like this that you want to
see me play so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]